you all know the emergency broadcast
system right we all grew up with that
true story thank you for offering to
answering me so succinctly and verbally
an entire crowd yes we do
true story starting tomorrow a new
version I'm not making this up a new
version of the emergency broadcast
system is going to allow President Trump
to send text to all of our cell phones
that's true that's a true thing yes
starting tomorrow Trump said I thought
I'd try announcing emergencies instead
of just causing them I'm freaked out by
that everyone in America is gonna get
three am angry text while he's on the
toya that's that's our new reality yeah
witch-hunt Wow it's just Trump okay for
a political environment very heated
political environment at a party last
night Trump supporter and apprentice
producer Mark Burnett physically
assaulted Tom Arnold yeah Arnold was
unhurt and said it's nice to be
recognized show business party and he
choked him yes yes it's insanity yeah
makes me wish I'd been there yeah you
and I always wish we were at those
parties a recent poll came out it shows
when asked what their favorite Mexican
restaurant is Americans overwhelmingly
said Taco Bell
yeah as soon as they heard this Mexico
offered to pay for the wall they'll
build it
that's really good mine work Andy that
Sharia that's really good I put the okay
whatever Walmart announced its gonna
finally open a store in New York City a
Walmart in New York City yeah because
it's New York City Walmart greeters are
gonna be allowed to say hey how the you
doing that's another show my mom's not
watching she's got a long streak going
uh this is crazy I don't nobody got any
football fans here in a football game
yesterday an NFL player realized he just
couldn't do it another minute and
retired in the middle of the game yeah
not crazy Andy
[Applause]
you